Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192. David P here is a caller
thrilled that Madison Cawthorn lost. I have
to tell you, I also am thrilled about it.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, it's John from North
Carolina. I'm just letting you know that I
love the show, baby. You do a great job. You do
some great coverage. Yes, sir. Yes, sir. And also,
I really just want to say that I'd like to
rejoice in the fact that Madison Cawthorn is no
longer in the mother in the house. Got out
of here, baby. I love you, David. Take care.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much for the
call. Yeah, it is. I mean, listen, we
I get it. The guy who beat Madison Cawthorn
is almost certainly going to be the winner
in that district and it will stay with a
Republican. It's not like Madison Cawthorn
is being replaced with a reasonable Democrat or
a progressive, but because Cawthorn is emblematic
of the debasement of American politics where a
completely incompetent clown with no, no business
being involved in politics wins thanks to the
combination of riding Trump's coattails and the
MAGA wave of the 2020 way. Yeah, well, all this
different stuff. It is still a good thing to see
him lose and see him removed. Will then have
to, you know, deal with the fact that the guy
who replaces him will probably be 80% is bad,
but it's okay to be happy about it. I'm happy.
Madison Cawthorn lost. He had no business being
there. And unfortunately, I don't know that we're
going to be as successful in making some as some
of these other MAGA people. One term members of
Congress. We're going to try. Don't get me wrong.
We're going to try. But I don't know that it will
be successful. Let's just be happy that he lost,
at least for the next day. We are going to talk
on the bonus show today. And this is that same
bonus show that Alex Jones has been talking about.
Speaker 2: The bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's the one I'm talking about.
A lawsuit is now seeking more than $2 million
in damages from the fake Republican electors in
Wisconsin. This would. Be beautiful, beautiful if
it succeeded. Number two, the FDA is announcing
some plans to ease the shortage of baby formula,
which is becoming an area of major concern.
Parents just worried, am I going
to have the formula to feed my kid?
And thirdly, a judge strikes down
Tennessee's transgender bathroom sign law.
This is this is a genuinely interesting case, and
it has to do with a lot of different things going
on at the federal level and at the state level
and elsewhere. So we're going to talk about that
on today's bonus show as well. If you want
to get access to the bonus show today,
very easy sign up at join Pacman dot com. You can
use the coupon code above now to get a discount
if you'd rather get the big discount on Memorial
Day. Fine. Fine with me. It's only 12 days away.
Get on my newsletter at David Pakman dot com. And
then Monday morning, Monday Memorial Day, you'll
get an email in which I will tell you how to take
advantage of this great membership discount. So,
no, no shame in waiting until Memorial
Day. We will see you on the bonus show
or otherwise. We'll be back
tomorrow with a brand new Jeff.